[Music]
uh okay let's take whatever I have to
play for a win
I could have probably given Perpetual
check but
ha ha
well he fell for the only cheap one that
I had
that's unbelievable
that's really unbelievable
I mean good game sir you played better
than I did most of the game
what can I say I mean I was out playing
positionally and then I got a cheapo
that's
that's not World Championship material
I'll tell you that
it's not what you're supposed to do
the guys in the lead Drew so I'm only a
half a point out now
because I'm with within a chance
in with a Chance
I probably if I win out I will tie for
first and then I'll have a poor tie
break
but that's a